STAND
O TURN TO WHAT'S GOING
NOW.A SERIOUS LOPMENT.THE KYIV F
VITAL DAM AND UNLEASHING A FLOO
>> Reporter: A NHAIA'S WARUKRAS.
SOON VASS STDED S OF CITY.
UKRAINITS ALLIESD  THE BREACTHAE
HEAPED BUTDINGA
UKRAINIAN CE A
TEN THE EA, MANY
TROOHOE TH
TH. POSITIO WHERE
Y DESTROYED AND FULLF
WATEHAVE
THEY ARE JUST RUNNIN.T OF THEIRO
UID NID
>> IF THISS UAI
ADVANTAGAN YOU BE SURE THAT
>> UKRAINE DT DESTRO
CONTROL.E IS A'S PRO FO
E MAIN PROBLEM IT CIVILIANS BECE
THE GOVERNMEMID  BY
STRUCTURAL FAILURET THEN THE LAA
NTMARC Y
>> Translar:
N OCCUPIERS.
AND THEY BLEW IT UP. RUSSIA SAYE
LD
LOEAST
AGAINE CIVILIAN
80 SETTLEMENTS AND TENS OFOU
FLOODING
CLEAN WATER AND POWESY
HAVEEED IN KHERSON
>> Translator: EVERYTHING IS DH
LIVING BIRDS,
HING WILL DI WILL BE DWN>> Repo
EY NOW FACE  ECOLOGICAL
MILITARY SAID THEYNTLIRY, , THE
THE DISASTER OE AND
THAT IT WOULDN'TR
FOR THCOUNTEFF
THE LIS IN TOWNS THAT
WOD NORMAL WATERS RESERVOI ME
ANO TH IN
MANYG TO COPE
RE WOLF.AM KILEY, THANK YO.HERET
SMAN JASON
INTELLIGENCE AND FOREIGN
COMMITTEE. DO THE SIGN
BASED ON EVERYTHU KNOW  FT
ATTACK THIS  THI AWFUL TRAGEDY,.
TO SUFFER  UEA AT THISI
BRIEFED ON ANY OF
THERN OF ANDRACTICE  IAN UT RIG?
EXECUTIONS, THEY HAVE KIDNAPPED
THOUSANDS OF UKRAINIANREN
AND SENT THE IRUSSIA AND THEY H
THERE IS NO REASONHY THE NS WOU
INFLICTING SUFFERING ON THEIR
OWN PEOPLE.FIGHTING F OWN
M.
IT WOULDN'T OR
PURPOSEFUL OR WHETHEEEPING I
RERI R CONTROL.
>> IF RUSSIA WAS, IN
RESPOND?NI
>>L, THI TT I'VE
DONE,
AN EFFORT  HE
RELEASE IT T INTERNATIONAL
CRIMINOURTHEPREC RUSSIAN WAR
CR.IN DECEMBER, I SRT AN EFFORT
ADMINISTRATION TO SHARE
INTELLIGEN WE C FOR
E PROSECUTIONS, THEY HAVE DONE
TODAY ACTUALLY RELEASED I
OV MY CO
PUBLICANS AND THAT
ENCOURAGED THE ADMINISTRATION TO
US BECAUSE
PERPETRATORS.
THESCRT D
ACCOUNTABLE STNGH
VLADIMIR PUTIN, HE'S ALREADY
BEEN INDICTED BY
ACTUALLY FOR TARNG A
AILE AN INFRASTRUCTURE BU
OFHEARGA THESE, YOU KNOWNG FORWD
REQUIRES ACCOUNTABILITFO